the Joe Rogan experience no I mean
there's so many people that are
insulated from the kind of life that
you've had they don't know anybody like
you you know so I'm realizing that Chris
my producer I scared of [ __ ] on him he's
like well you're yelling at me I'm like
Chris I'm not yelling you knowing a
black woman yell oh she got a twist and
honey
they're taking off her wig and unbuckle
it hot bra
I'm yelling I'm just talking my voice I
have a deep voice and this it carries
you know what's crazy cuz like I said
he's a little white kid from
Indianapolis you know so I'm talking to
on the podcast and I'm teaching them
about black [ __ ] incense you have heard
of that black [ __ ] incense yeah you
know that you burn a black people used
to burn in the house I know about
incense but like [ __ ] you slow me down
it wasn't real so we put out the podcast
it was like my mama say black [ __ ] is
it was the best scent out there Joe okay
what did you smell like incense yeah
that was the name of a night so I told
him about me like what are you talking
about I'm telling you black [ __ ] is it
everybody lives in the Arkell it burnt
black [ __ ] incense on a Saturday
morning clean the house everybody listen
to our Kelly and burn black so every
weekend every week I'm teaching him
something that he has never heard of
what do you think about all this art oh
shut I think you did it Joe if people
just look the way you know it's I tell a
bit on stage does it something about a
big big man big dick black man they
can't read they puts it down my first
kid can read everyone ain't got no side
teeth and they can't read they got the
best sex cuz they practice out of time
black men who can't read don't have six
like black means who got a nine-to-five
who can't read the sex is totally
different because they're not tired
because they practice how they do it
practice on
women but you got my husband gotta go to
work Joey he got tired be flipping me
over Stephanie cross him well you got a
brother that Kate reading don't work the
best six now you know go to work but you
gonna watch The Young and the Restless
and Housewives of Atlanta
well you know when you get back that
that dig is laying on that pillow for
you I know we used to wade through big
money putting down you know you had to
work even harder because yeah more money
than him right yeah that's true so I had
a meme they put up on the Instagram the
other day of how every dude whose
girlfriend is paying for everything
stands and it's like a guy standing with
his arm deep around the girl like deep
around holding on oh they're waiting in
line for things baby in public hallways
baby holding a hand you can't get my
husband to hold my hand
you know why can you pay the mortgage
[Laughter]
home yes si I love you say thank you I'm
in the big I was gonna follow my dream
one day my so I said listen to my
husband my husband funny as [ __ ] so I
said hey I said it up maybe you want
some [ __ ]
he said not at all hey I'm gonna you to
[ __ ] me on the fourteen because I think
I'm ovulating I need to get some stuff
off my chest
he said not at all Joe we bought a Sleep
Number bed and he's like cuz his knee
was mr. lung body sneaked number I'm
gonna put it on everything I'm like [ __ ]
yeah so I just got a deal with Fox for
my TV show so I walk in there I walk in
the damn mom sleep now my like a real
negro when they get some money give me a
best [ __ ] bad you won't cuz I'm gonna
[ __ ] every night this is owe me a
$13,000 Sleep Number bed but I should
have no you were gonna do [ __ ] cuz he
was insistent on getting a metric that
split down the middle you know the two
metric separate let's just split down
the middle and help the here time I want
an say I tell a you want to come to
America again [ __ ] with you all that
mattress juice all fall down
come here and in that we don't gave up
we just [ __ ] the middle and by the
time we get met through the [ __ ]
matches on fell off the because we in
the middle with a whole lap and every
time just [ __ ] my wig I give my TV show
all about me imagine that put us back
the [ __ ] gay
[Laughter]
[Applause]